all right now we're on to the fun stuff
can we start optimizing now yep let's
just focus on the steps before the
render tree construction so the DOM and
CSS on because those are usually the
steps that are the worst offenders and
make your page renderer very slowly well
we did talk about streaming HTML to the
client as fast as possible so the
browser can start building the dom is
there anything else so that's definitely
one what about the size of the HTML mmm
well I'm gonna go ahead and guess we
should keep it as small as possible yeah
that's another good one let's take a
look at some strategies that will help
us with this let's say we want to
optimize the HTML file in front of us
the first thing to notice is that we
have CSS comments HTML comments and
JavaScript comments now these comments
are very helpful for developers but
guess what the browser is going to do
when it encounters them it's gonna
ignore them exactly there's no point
than even shipping them to the browser
we can minify the file and reduce its
size to learn more about minification
check the link in the instructor notes
once you've done that you should also
compress the file and make sure they are
cached by the browser once again check
the instructor notes